hate these rankings sometimes because
it's like when you're getting into 26
films saying like where do you rank it
it could get kind of exhaustive there's
only like one other movie i think below
this that's fresh maybe two where do you
place it and i'll just say top three
middle or bottom tier
where's age of ultron
okay we're going to continue our deep
dive discussion of doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness with a section
we call after thoughts where we go to
discuss some of the lingering questions
left by the film and theorize what could
be in store for the future with our
guest caramel horn thank you so much for
joining us and so i hate these rankings
sometimes because it's like when you're
getting into 26 films saying like where
do you rank it it could get kind of
exhaustive but it's clearly in about
mid-level
uh to lower tier for audience score at
87 most marvel movies are in the high
80s i'm sorry in the high nine low 90s a
high 80s range
uh and it is down towards the very
bottom of an mcu film however i will
admit there is a huge drop off
from uh basically 70s down to the very
bottom uh entries where do you place it
and i'll just say top three middle or
bottom tier
where's age of ultron
because i literally i it's definitely
not top tier
um
i'm gonna say middle bottom
because again i think
that there are things in this film that
are going to be incredibly important
moving forward um they didn't stick the
landing and i think it has it's it's a
multitude of things
pandemic
uh
putting a lot of stuff on disney plus
versus on screen
directors in and out rewrites re-edits
uh so i think that yeah i can't put it
at the top i can't even put the top of
the mid i'm gonna say mid to lower tier
okay that's fair i
would say that that's about accurate um
also though it's weird for me
i put it higher in my mind because i
know that it had to do more
than what most mcu films are asked to do
and i always like to sort of grade on a
bit of a curve and i personally feel
like this film had a way higher ask than
your average mcu movie like that's like
the gods honest truth and so the fact
that this is such a
enjoyable film not a perfect film but
it's such an enjoyable film i will
forever um
[Music]
yeah i will forever think that it's it's
a little bit better than maybe the score
or even people's reaction will think and
it'll definitely be one of these movies
in 10 years they're gonna be like ah i'm
more excited for more sam raimi in the
mcu than anything else uh or at least
more sam raimi coming back and and
taking big swings with big budget
enterprise
yeah me too because i think
there is a chance it for him to do his
thing in the future in other
in other
series but it's the reason why i also
said uh
mid low and i also was asking about age
of ultron is because i remember when i
first saw age of ultron same thing with
this i was like ah but then later when i
rewatched it after seeing a bunch of
other things i was like you know what
that's a pretty good movie
when i think of so i i'm gonna agree
with you in terms of it had to do more
it had to lift way more yeah than most
uh uh mcu films so i do i definitely
agree with you there i don't want to
rage too hard against marketers because
they have one job just get people to see
the movies and no offense the people
that are like raging about spoilers or
people like us they've got our money
anyways but what do you think is that
right formula when you're looking ahead
to say okay
we want to
show parts of the movie but maybe not
show too much or are you saying like
look people still showed up in droves
for this one and they gave away half of
the movie in the
uh in the trailers so what does it
really matter
i i think it's a little of both i think
they
did give away quite a bit and even feige
commented on this he's like yeah they
kind of gave away too much um and but
you're right a lot of people complaining
about it are people who are very much in
the know that's why i think they should
do less especially on the tv spots
and give that
give those exclusives to
sites that have and cater to specific
fans because that's what they're going
for anyway it's just going to confuse
people who are not fans and for those
who just don't want to be spoiled um you
know besides staying off the internet
it's it's kind of making it tough
because a lot of those the spoiling
stuff was on network television it
wasn't even on social media it's so
interesting you brought up the sort of
like spot things i didn't watch enough
of uh
of the tv spots to really get spoiled
i'd seen the only thing that was minorly
spoiled was patrick stewart and john
krasinski
nothing else was spoiled for me but i
guess you felt like a lot of it was
spoiled
yeah but you know what i spent a lot
more time on twitter so
and i am
trying uh
desperately
not to be on twitter more often like i
really really am like it's just not good
for me like
you're like it's way too stressful away
yeah it's like no i'm good i i do not i
do not need this in my existence as this
is probably broadcasting on twitter as
we speak um
this is what's interesting this is set
up um i love the johnna lynch in this
cameo as well too because for folks that
don't know she was originally going to
play
the part that um
dionna wise played in the original
captain marvel correct
that is what i read yeah yes and then
now she's coming back for the marvels
with both
captain our
current version with brie larson and now
they're also going to get a maria rambo
captain marvel in the same movie which
is being directed by mia decosta uh who
directed candyman and so
it's like a lot of the folks who i'd
want to see in the mcu are already kind
of getting there uh
i i don't even know what it is but i'll
just put it out there my three celebrity
emily blood emily blunt emily blood i'm
still like look i just want to see her
in a uniform the only reason why she's
not is because of meryl streep which is
stupid and gulliver's travels which is
even stupider and
after you watch a movie like edge of
tomorrow how can you not want her in the
mcu any celebrities you want to see in
the mcu
um there are several but before i i uh
mention them i i agree with you
scarlett johansson's outside mcu issues
aside i do believe that
the whole thing was just not ham just
uh natasha's character as a whole just
wasn't handled properly in the mcu and
so i do agree now you know when i
finally learned that you know emily
could have been her that and then
she could have also been just another
red room age there's just so many things
that could have happened when again
choices were made um people i want to
see in the mcu uh janelle monae
yeah that's a great one um
lana condor and i will tell you why
i got a chance to interview lana years
ago
when she was in that x-men movie that we
don't talk about anymore
and she
and apocalypse and she was so excited
about her role and all the things that
she was going to be doing she's a huge
marvel comic book head and they cut
everything that she did out
um in fact they put more of her in the
ads for the movie than in the movie
itself
i
when we do get a proper x-men i want her
recast as jubilee and i want it done
properly
because they did her wrong
[Music]
um but yeah
if janelle monae could be
storm uh or
any other entity
uh in in the mcu i would i would love
that i would love it
um but i could be here all day also you
know what i'm sorry i know people have
said it but keanu reeves should be in
there somewhere yeah and apparently he's
had conversations apparently but this is
the thing so many of the people who i'd
want to see names you already are or
about to be like i look at somebody like
mahershala of course he should be in the
mcu i look at somebody like keanu and of
course they should be in the mcu they're
already talking about it i still to this
day love it when it's not people we're
thinking about when when when chadwick
got got um cast at as as black panther i
think black folks knew who he was
because he played james brown and he
played jackie robinson and he had
already been very big within our
community but i think a lot of folks
didn't know who he was and so i like
that when that happens because
then there's a place to go and then or
even when folks maybe push outside of
type for whatever role that they end up
being cast in i'm all for that so as
much as i want well-known people i'm
more about like let's write the
injustices i'm still mad about
emily blunt and then after that i i
trust i trust
um
sarah
uh haley finn or sarah finn haley she is
the casting director for the mcu and she
has been responsible for every single
casting that we've seen from robert
downey jr down to sochi and
i put faith in her making decision like
casting flory and monteneux as razer
fists any woman that can see the
potential comedy and cinema in that man
playing that role i'm a trust she knows
what's going on
and listen i i agree with you if we're
gonna
if we do go with
i don't want to say unknowns but
unknowns outside of certain circles um
if we're going maybe for an older uh uh
the
x-men storm utili bizaki if we're going
younger yara shahidi if we're going you
know it but i still want my young
avengers i still want them like to put
all the
kids that we've seen on disney plus and
give them a show so they could do their
thing and then the show they're not
gonna give them a movie i think marvel's
gonna be very strategic from now on
which stories
make sense in a cinematic setting versus
which ones make sense in a television
setting and they actually set that brew
plant before disney plus they set that
blueprint with netflix and abc and now
they're just cultivating on disney plus
that's true that's true luke cage broke
netflix yeah
at their house and more importantly they
saw the mistakes of something like
inhumans and they saw some of the i
wouldn't say mistakes of agents of
shield but let's be honest the asian
shield twisted itself into so many plot
hole knots
that
like you couldn't even see here's but
the problem is agents of shield
and
granted you really need to start
mid season one not at the beginning and
jump out before the end it was the
problem is it so much of its storyline
was built around in humans because they
just thought in humans was going to be
amazing that when it wasn't and then
humans got yanked they just didn't have
a net and then it turned into like they
jumped the shark after that it was like
wait what is happening where are we how
many colsons he's bad what like that's
not what i signed up for like we didn't
all petition for colson to come back to
see this
this is very true which which actually
begs the question because we only have a
couple more minutes before we get out of
here what's the next thing because the
first few years was all leading to end
game so like what is
the big
i would say ask or what is going to be
the big event uh going forward and i
think for me personally
knowing that we have x-men coming
no more mutants
i mean come on we've got it we gotta do
that right like is that where this is
all going i think everything we're going
forward is just going to be more
x-men versions of the mcu that lead to
big x-men events
it's possible um but they again they
mention incursions too many times for
them not to open this door and there's
two things that could happen the
incursions jonathan hickman's
avengers new avengers 2012-2013
fanboys don't show up in my mentions
it's around that time
um
that what he built in there which ended
up with basically these worlds time
periods
crashing into each other and ending up
with this battle world
secret world secret wars battle world
scenario where you had this
almost god like dr doom tied to the
fantastic four again
i think that's we're heading i think
we're heading to another
endgame level event which is going to be
secret wars it's not gonna happen right
away we gotta introduce a bunch of other
people x-men fantastic four blade all
that because everybody got to fight
here's the other thing about it
but do you think that's the next big
event i think that's the next big end
game not the next big not the next big
event i don't know i mean like then then
i would say x-men
um
again my brain right now is kind of on
black panther too
and i know for the fact that in the
comics the incursion started in wakanda
and so it's just too easy and now that
we know that winston duke has like more
of a role
and we know that michael b jordan is
coming back
that i don't know why nobody's wrote
about this yet but
maybe i need to pitch this but i
i can see
these multiverse versions like we saw on
what if
of
of killmonger being the king of wakanda
of or of uh the king of wakanda ending
up being
a jabari leader like baku like all of
these things are all possible the
the big thing that they've done with
this movie is confirmed that anything is
possible because they've broken up this
universe that there's a there's a thing
that fikey said that they started in
motion in uh spider-man as well as loki
where the worlds are colliding
so i think the next big event could be
x-men but here's the thing if the next
big event is fantastic four i don't
think they have to start at the
beginning
i think they're i don't think we need to
see the origins oh how they meet how
they get married have i
the next big thing uh event or problem
or issue could just have them show up
and now where'd they come from oh we're
from earth
19999 like you know um so i am looking
forward to
and the other thing this does is open up
casting
because there's always with this worry
that certain actors are going to age out
or be less interested or drop out of
their roles or whatever
um
and opening up the universe like this
basically gives the mcu free reign to
cast whoever they want even if they go
kill them in an unsatisfying way like
they did in uh doctor strange multiverse
madness
yes but again it's still just one world
there's 60 other places that you can go
and to your point that means yeah if we
didn't like one of these versions we
could do another one uh just to sort of
like tie off on sam raimi to tie off on
on what multiverse advantage sort of set
up and what it could set up
a lot of people are talking about trying
to get a spider-man 4.
i will tell you me personally i'm not
one of these people i just am not i'm
not either i'm not one of these people
but the one thing i will say is
i do want to give sam raimi a chance to
make a spider-man movie have it be its
last spider-man movie where he didn't
get shoved toe for grace because still
to this day apparently topher grace
basically signaling to sony while he was
at the height of his that 70s show power
that he wanted to do a movie is what
literally derailed all of sam raimi's
plans for the final movie like oh
there was not gonna be venom
they were gonna hint at venom coming but
the tom hayden christensen character of
sandman was going to be the big villain
there was gonna be no venom and if you
look at the movie from that lens you
can't help but anything because all of
the great character development all the
great character
plot in that movie went to thomas hayden
church and that was actually going to be
probably a movie that set him on a path
for 10 years later of making
blockbusters and that movie actually
hurt everybody's career in it we don't
get emo toby with no venom we don't get
dancing in the street with no venom we
don't get toby being to marry jane with
no venom like
for everything we gained by adding that
character we lost so much more so for
that respect i would like to see sam
remy have the swan song that he enjoyed
but i'm okay if he doesn't get it
it's it's interesting that she said that
because i i would like to see sam raimi
do a venom movie but if you bring him
into the marvel universe it's gotta be
with peter and so here's the thing i
love
i'm not saying i i don't like spider-man
or i don't like the movies i do it's
just
there's so many so much spider-man over
the past few years and we're trying to
get like i need to get to blade i need
to get i want to see some other things
yeah i want to see you know
i i would even like to see uh rainey do
something like a marvel nights and we've
got you know
just another iteration
of
a missed opportunity was having raymie
do
an x-men fan i'm sorry an x-men movie
with the demon bear saga
that
was not dubbed by my i wish they had
held on to that one or gotten that one
from them because sam raymond would have
done a really good job with that um
i as far as this movie is concerned
here's the thing it's not a terrible
movie if you are if anybody who's
watching this doesn't know that much
about the comics doesn't know doesn't
have disney plus
um it might be a little confusing but
it's a fun ride if you know tangentially
if you've watched some of disney plus
but you don't know follow the comics i
think you're gonna have a good time
if you're a sam raimi's fan from from
the first ash
to the last
you are probably going to have a ball
looking at all of the little easter eggs
and everything that they give you um but
overall i just don't think this is
marvel's best film it's not their worst
but it had to happen in order for the
rest of phase four to continue and and
basically open up opportunities for
other storylines yeah i agree it
it's like i don't love it but i
understand and on that note
on that note
we will call it a day uh carama thank
you thank you thank you so much for
joining us i've alluded to it but let
folks know what you're working on and
where they can find you
uh well you can find me the blurred girl
everywhere basically uh clearly i'm on
twitter more than jacqueline
and i'm also across social uh check out
the blur girl podcast i also have a live
twitch show on tuesdays
as well as a book that you can now
pre-order called protectors of wakanda i
was able to write the origin story of
the dorm lager
marvel let me do it uh it's not a comic
it is a why a novel but it's going to
drop in september and i would really
appreciate it if everybody could uh
pre-order it because i had a lot of fun
and the incursion actually affected some
of my storyline too
wow i like this i love i love hearing
how it's all a part of this mcu formula
and you tangentially were like
i got reported too by marvel where i can
go
all right
that's it for us for another episode of
the after show again i'm jacqueline
kohler you can find me over around
tomatoes.com or anywhere on the internet
at that jaclyn and we will see y'all
next time
bye bye
[Music]
you